all my life since i was young and from
what i was reading i believe that jesus
was an amazing prophet he was a human
um and it didn't make any common sense
how could jesus be god was to believe in
jesus so alhamdulillah we believe in
jesus as one of the mightiest we believe
in jesus we love jesus i i became an
ordained minister
you became a christian ordained minister
if for those that don't know what jinn
are they're like um
evil spirits they call it the bible but
then you got the king's very version the
mormons have their bible jehovah
witnesses have theirs
protestants have theirs the methodists
have theirs
um verses are missing but there is this
quran
that has never been changed this last
part when you were going over just gave
me chills
muhammadin
this is
subscribe if you haven't already we got
another exciting episode my next guest
went from being baptized
at a young age of nine
in the methodist church
to shortly after that some time later
being involved in the southern baptist
church
and then from there in the
denominational church
and at the same time being a designated
driver now for those of you that don't
know that we're going to define these
terms get to know more of her story
to what led her to finally being here
with us on the dean show
with my next guest karen khadija
assalaamu alaikum sister alaikum assalam
peace be with you how are you sister
alhamdulillah
so did we get that right at nine years
old you were baptized at the methodist
church um i was uh first christian as a
catholic
um
uh when i was a very young child and so
of course we went to the catholic church
but
um
i kept searching and then at the age of
nine yes uh without my parents
permission i went to the methodist
church
and
they were it shocked them
that i became baptized in the methodist
church
so then how did you end up in the
southern baptist church
the way i grew up it was you go in the
military or you get
married military so
um
at the time i had a boyfriend and so i
got married he was military of course
but he was he was baptist southern
baptist
and uh
so
that meant basically
we're going to baptist i tried to go to
the methodist church a little bit but
you know when you you follow your
husband's
route and then every year basically
because military we moved
what's the main difference between the
methodist church
that you started off with and then the
southern baptist church what are the
main main differences
there's really not much main differences
um
they're more
how do you want to put um
i felt more open in a methodist church
than i was in a baptist church you know
you had to follow and this is the way it
was and don't ask the questions
and you're blindly following like sheep
that's what i would call it
that's for which one the southern
baptist
the baptist um
baptists were a little bit more strict
than the methodist methodist is more
open
um
and i think what they do
when for me in the in the methodist
church it was they try to change things
to make it
completely acceptable for everybody
not just
the way it should be as far as
straightway
um
and they put a lot of both of the
churches
um
put a lot of their opinion you know how
you you pick pieces and parts
from the bible and um
then they
make their
their opinion or story to
get their point across
but in most cases what they're picking
out that's not what it means
and from there you you end up so you but
the creed is pretty much the same that
jesus the belief that jesus is part of a
trinity a triune on the cross um and
that that's you had to go through jesus
before you could get through anything
else and if you didn't believe in jesus
then you were going to hell
i just didn't understand that because
to me all my life since i was young and
from what i was reading i believe that
jesus was an amazing prophet he was a
human
um and it didn't make any common sense
how could jesus be god
it just
at a very young age i just didn't
understand it and that meant and led to
a lot of arguments and
basically that i was a bad child because
i wouldn't believe the way it was
the way we were supposed to be raised
and
um even when i became a muslim it was i
was a traitor to my religion
uh to my family and to the traditions
and the cultural so
um it was a big
uh
big shock to my family
um
but to me i came it it brought me peace
and that's what i was searching for was
peace in my life and understanding
because the questions that i had
they started being answered
you know
now did you say this term a lot in both
churches or just uh one or the other no
no i i mean this term hallelujah is this
familiar with you hallelujah i love that
um all the time yeah
i'm saying in the choir
um i love singing um i think that was
some of the things that
that worried me as i came into islam
um i know now that
being a muslim is between god
me and allah and um
a lot of different terms but yes
that was
the the reason i say that is because i
say hallelujah or alhamdulillah which
just means
which means all praises to the creator
that has never got almighty that because
you said earlier that you will end up
the only way
to receive salvation or to get to
paradise or what you said was to believe
in jesus so alhamdulillah we believe in
jesus as one of the mightiest we believe
in jesus we love jesus
people don't seem to understand
um they don't seem to understand that
jesus is is also number one in our lives
you know we do believe in him we believe
in his miracles and what he did and what
he came for and what he stood for and
alhamdulillah the messiah will come back
and which he will um
but in his time there's nobody knows
gonna happen you know only
and um
so
but forced
is you know every time you turn if you
disagreed with some church you were
going to hell
didn't understand that
yeah many people don't know that if you
reject in islam submission to the
creator not the creation if you reject
belief if you deny jesus or say any
derogatory thing
against him peace we say peace be upon
him that's how you can get to the
hellfire by disrespecting jesus but we
love him as a mighty messenger but we
respectfully say that he never claimed
to be god a part of god he wasn't part
of a trinity he called people to worship
the one and only creator of the heavens
and earth the same way abraham moses and
the last and final master prophet
muhammad
uh worshiped the creator so
alhamdulillah so you go from the
methodist church to the southern baptist
church and then you find yourself in a
non-denominational church
uh yes um so i kept searching
um like i said i always had questions
and at the same time something just kept
you know even though you're going
through life and doing work and
raising children and there was just
pieces were missing and i wanted to find
those and
so with all the fighting that churches
do between each other that one religion
is better than theirs um
i then went to a non-denominational
church and i started studying with them
and they basically didn't care what your
belief was
um they just wanted you to be a member
um
and so i would do some articles i would
write i would do more studying
um
i went to their little seminary schools
and
it turned out that basically
you know the more i became an ordained
minister
um and i thought hey i like this you
know i'm an ordained minister i have a
little i have a little card still
somewhere in my office um staying
reverend
carolyn
and um
so
that felt
i was almost you know i felt like i was
there and i was done
and
then i think it was a little bit time
after that just
something kept questioning myself like
something was missing
and so
at the same time i think i stepped back
because i called myself an independent
spiritualist
um
because whenever i tried to talk about
god and tell people look god wants you
to be with him he wants you to thank him
that's
the number one thing and that's to me
thanking him is worshiping him
um
but he uh you know allah
is kind he's not what i grew up with
of
every you know how do you want to say it
he always
was you need to fear him i mean really
fear him to where
you were scared to death of him
and allah is so amazing
he's so merciful so forgiving and yeah
we make mistakes for human we're not
perfect
and
but if we recognize and try to grow
closer to him and recognize our faults
and work on those faults and try to be a
better person
that's what allah wants to see
and i so like i said i became an
ordained minister i would go talk to
people
and i think a lot of it was the way i
was living and then all of a sudden um
and
this is where you were talking about
designated driver i had
a best friend from high school that i've
known her for 30 years and every time i
turned around she wanted to go out
and i was just not a person who
i don't know i just i didn't feel
comfortable going out
um she wanted me to dress up she would
do my makeup she would do my hair and i
just
you know you're out there flaunting
yourself
you know and i always felt
self-conscious about myself
and um
so
when we would go out of course
i guess i'm the responsible one
she would do all the drinking and
then i would always be worried
and so i would be the designated driver
for whoever was in the group
um to make sure everybody got home safe
yeah many people haven't heard that term
or if they haven't designated driver as
soon as you say that that means there's
going to be some drinking involved
there's going to be some part partying
and and the way and the memories from
all of that just um
i mean i don't know if you want to say
they were what we call good times if
you're going out partying all the time
um
but
you're just
you don't there's a lot of stuff you
don't remember um
and
drinking just you know just i don't know
it just didn't uh
i've tried it i've done it
but i'm just not into it you know i just
it just kept something inside me kept
bothering me
yeah just imagine how many lives just
what you said just stood out you know
there's a lot of things i don't remember
how many women men how many people just
black out and then they end up you know
being raped
uh molested you know taken advantage of
because of that alcohol islam protects
you from that so obviously muslims don't
even have a sip of it they're not
supposed to or man he does something you
know that he's not supposed to do
because he's intoxicated right and then
he just loses his whole life
right that's has in front of him because
he got involved in these things that the
creator out of his love told us to stay
away from one of those things
and that's something
something about alcohol you just can't
have one
um
and it's
it when it gets to you it just
how do you want to say it sucks you in
um and you just you keep drinking and
then you don't realize
and then until it's too late and
uh pass outs and throwing up all the
time and you know that's just
what i mean in all reality is there
really any fun into that
i'd rather be playing a game of cards
and
doing things with my family and my
friends that are my sisters the islamic
sisters i have now
we have picnics we have get-togethers
and we have an enjoyable free time that
and we talk about the quran we talk
about allah
that
you know
you'll remember from time on it's
something that you you'll remember and
you grow with
some actual positive bonding tell me uh
what
this term that you use uh ordained
minister so you as a woman you became a
christian ordained minister yes yes
tell how how did that happen
um well actually um when we were doing
the seminary i've always
felt
like i belonged to allah
um
since i was a little girl and i was very
fascinated with nuns i don't know why um
but
i just for some reason i just when it
was offered to me i i said yes
um i thought that would be an exciting
step i thought that would be the the
last step i didn't i had no idea
out of all the religions that i studied
um
i never studied about islam which was
the funny part out of it because the
christian church don't
they don't acknowledge it
i mean now in today's society yes they
do but back then no they did not
[Music]
tell me now as a ordained
minister
you
obviously you had some questions still
you were concerned about the trinity you
used to call jesus peace be upon him a
wonderful prophet
so how was it were you still battling
with that because now you're in a higher
position or ordained minister but now
you're having trouble with you know the
basic this is the creed this is the
foundation
of the religion this trinity right so
then how are you going through this
calling him a wonderful prophet which
actually the bible calls him a prophet
we believe he was a messenger a prophet
so how did you battle between these two
and then when you went to some of your
seniors or people
some of the people in the church to
question them about some of these
questions you had what kind of response
did you get well questioning about it
was one of those things where you
believe it or not and that's it it was
taboo you just didn't talk about it um
it's one of those things where yes i did
battle and i you know i battled with it
for a long time even though i became
ordained
um it was the fact that
i was like well maybe i am wrong maybe
i'll just accept it
um i just give up and just go with the
flow
um that's what kept get making me go i
didn't want to go with the flow
um
because you know you talk about it and
you listen you're like
i just really you know in your head
you're like nah
but on the outside you're like oh okay
yeah and you wouldn't talk you would you
would skip around those questions
so that you didn't have to get
deep into it because if i went to go get
deep into it i'd really sit there and
say okay excuse me wait a minute how do
you get the father the son and the holy
ghost is one
it doesn't make any sense i remember i
studied one time with the mormons um and
they said well you accept this and i
said i have a question for you and i
know it sounds silly the first thing i
said was i said okay so you believe in
the father the son and the holy ghost
i said who's to say that the holy ghost
is not a woman
and you should have seen their faces
they just like
like i must have said something really
really bad or something
and um
they're like
okay but
how does
i mean i can understand
when you do something you become one but
you're not actually one so it's just
like a symbolism
part but
god is god
and alhamdulillah
um
i use the term god
when i'm around my friends of course and
they're mostly arabic it's allah but
when i speak to a lot of people that are
not muslim
i use the the word god because people
are scared to death of
i guess arabic language i don't
i don't understand how that one but i
try to explain to them that allah is his
name that's one of his names yeah let me
just take a moment and define some of
these terms for the not yet muslims
non-muslims who are coming in muslim is
simply one who has chosen to
freely submit to the creator that
heavens and earth the same god that
jesus worshiped abraham moses and the
last fundamental problem muhammad peace
be upon him
and all them and allah like you said
jews and christians who are arabic
speaking they use the term allah
and the sister language to arabic is
aramaic and that's the language jesus
spoke so when you heard this term allah
now you freely use it
and when you even in the bible in the
arabic language allah is mentioned 17
times around in the first
page in the book of genesis so this is
not and and it's encyclopedia britannica
uh talks about jesus calling on god by
allah
allah
uh
elohim you know in in hebrew so
this english language uh didn't exist
back then so how would they have called
god this is just something to think
about but when now when you started to
learn about this word allah when you
started to use it
um how how was it at that time you know
the
impression that you were getting how was
how did you make that transition to
what you knew about allah before and
what you were learning now and was it
easy to understand actually um it was
kind of nice that i finally had a name
um because when you say god
a lot of times
people don't realize that it's one
you know as soon as you say god they
think jesus
um
and i try to get people to understand
the term allah that that's one of his
names
and to call him that and it all it is is
god in arabic
um as far as the transition
i felt more at peace
with myself
because
i felt like i was getting closer to him
because now i have a better connection
because when um
sit down and pray
and
allah that's it's me you know talking to
allah
personally
there's uh this
infomercial that's being put out
and it's by
a
christian organization
and what they're doing is they're
putting on portraying a woman who used
to be supposedly muslim
and now one of the talking points she
has this is like now when someone goes
on youtube it's one of those commercials
that pops up and i've seen this quite a
few times
so one of the talking points is that
she says that oh i fell into this this
and that and all this bad stuff but i
didn't know who to turn to and i was
trained or taught that allah is just so
like you know
angry and he is just so there's no
forgiveness from with allah and then i
have to turn to jesus and what would you
say to so because you mentioned earlier
how merciful allah is and this is one of
the misconceptions that many people you
know falsely put out there what what
would you say to someone like that
i would say she needs to do a lot of
searching within herself
um i think that she's following other
people and what they say because she's
got
a resentment
um
you know
in this religion
it's a personal thing between you and
allah
and
when you and yes there are times that
you can get angry with allah
because you're not getting the way
that you want your life to go
and acceptance is the number one thing
but
when you follow him
and it's it's
when you put him number one
first in your life
he is so merciful
the miracles that are around here
um
you know you just a lot of people don't
see them and i would say that uh either
jinn which are
um
if for those that don't know what jin
are they're like um
evil spirits
um or shaitaan which is the devil is
enticing her
to go a different direction and keep her
and we will all be tested that's
you know that's ex that's expected you
can't sit there and think
that you go into another change of
lifestyle
um
another religion and not think that
you're not going to get tested allah it
says he will test the best of those
that he tests those that he loves and
and the ones that he you know
the closer you get the more tests you're
gonna have
um
and when bad things happen to me the
first thing i say to myself because you
know
you get you get agitated you're a human
you're going to get agitated and
irritated
and i can sit in my car and i say yeah
allah i you know and i realize
that something that came through my head
that the shaitaan or jinn is there and
the first thing i say to myself is you
know this is a test this is a test of my
faith
and
i'm not going to let go of allah i don't
care how much i get tested i'm still
going to be
a muslim i'm still going to be
with islam
because i found that's what is in my
heart now
and
when i do that
it's like all of a sudden it dissipates
you know because it's like
i think
the shaytan is always going to be there
but
god is there first so i would say to her
that she needs to really do some
searching on herself
um and understand why she's so upset
with allah
tell me uh the next transition of your
story
in this timeline so we went from the
different churches non-denominational
you being ordained minister and then
you've ended up meeting a muslim woman
is that right and then from there yeah
that was the fun part um and the most
interesting part so this girl that i was
always the designated driver for and we
would go out and she would get drunk and
we would go party and that's how she
wanted to always live she happens to
show up one night and um
we were supposed to go out that night
and she turned around she says oh i
found somebody that looks and acts just
like you
and i said what
and i said what do you mean acts like me
she says oh the one you never want to
drink you don't want to party you don't
want to dress up she says so i found
somebody like you but she just wears
this scarf around her head
and i said really
and i perked up and i said hmm i'd
really like to meet this young lady
and
she was like
oh okay so then we went out partied came
home
and
a couple months later i kept bugging her
i would call her and i said have you
have you talked to that girl
and she says oh yeah we'll get a time to
meet up and then all of a sudden we
finally got time to wear all of us
because she was in nursing school
and um
we all sat down one day to meet
and
she i went and told her
all the stuff that had happened through
my life about how i kept searching she
opened up the quran um
it was in arabic and english version she
started pointing some things out and she
looked at me and she says
she says you know with a laugh she says
you know what she says
all your life
you have been living
like a muslim i said no i have not what
are you talking about she says no
the good deeds that you do the kindness
wanting to search for allah
praying coming closer to him
being nice and being good and and
just being a caring person
um
the good that was being done that's what
she uh
turned around and so i said well you
know
what is a muslim what how do you become
one because you know i was like okay
what's going on here
and she just around she says you just
have to say the shahada
i said the shahada what in the world is
that and she says was
muhammad rasulullah and i was like
okay english please
and she turned around she says the fact
that there is only one god
and that muhammad peace be upon him is
the last messenger
and when you accept allah as one
and the messenger is this last prophet
who came for all of mankind not just
uh a certain tribe because if you look
in the bible every prophet that showed
up
came for a specific tribe back in those
days
and
she says you know i said well do you
just she says you'll know
when you're ready
she says but it's good when you feel it
to accept the shahada because from then
you start off like a new baby
and
your sins are forgiven
and you start from there
and then you learn to to
change your lifestyle even more
and for the good
and so i thought that was kind of cool
and we finished right then and there and
she went home in her way and then i of
course
now i'm really into the internet
um looking some stuff up and
a couple days later i met up with a
friend who
um
a brother
that i didn't know was a brother at the
time
and
he was a friend of my father well when
my father had passed away he like took
over
you know
if i ever needed to have somebody to
speak with
um we would sit down have coffee and and
sit down and speak
and so
i sat down with him over at the coffee
shop
and i turned around i said you're not
gonna believe it so i explained who i
met what i was saying what i thought and
then i told him i said you know what i
was thinking i said last night i between
me and and allah
i went ahead and said the shahada i
really believe
that this is the right direction to go
and that's when he looked at me and he
says welcome home and i said what does
that mean welcome home he says
masha'allah
you finally got here
and i said jude what
what are you talking about he says
i'm a muslim i said what i said so for
the last 10 15 years i've known you with
my father you're a muslim
and he said yes and i said well why
didn't you tell me anything about this
and he said
you have had so much going on in your
life
and so many different struggles
that i didn't want to confuse you
even more
and bring something else into your life
until you were ready
and he says we don't it's it's not
compulsion we don't force people to come
into islam
this is something that you want you have
to want it
and
i was like i'm not being forced that was
you know i was like
you mean
you didn't talk to me because you
thought i would before he says no you
when you're a muslim you come in freely
none of us are forced to come be a
muslim even a muslim born
muslim is not a muslim until they take
the shahada
and
just because you know then that's
something i learned through time
um
but uh
yeah it was so interesting to to see
that's how and now i understood where
all his patience came from and why he
was the way he always was very quiet
very wise in his words and he'd always
think
before he did things
so how far after how far along after
that conversation with him did you
actually officially accept islam
well i went to the the um what we have
the small little islamic center in fort
walton beach um and about a month later
exactly um october 11th 2011
i publicly came out and said the shahada
and at first i didn't understand why
and then i realized uh after they
explained it to me
yes you
it is a religion between you and and
allah
but when you come out publicly and you
say it in front of
the other people that are in the
measured
they now know that you're a muslim
and
you everybody gets taken care of
um
when you become a muslim they now like
said it's it's
it's one big family
i have met so many muslims around the
world that
if i had a lot of money and could really
travel i would have a place to stay
everywhere
just
you know because they're they've become
family
um
and it's amazing and
i'm it's not gonna always happen for
everybody
you're gonna have everybody goes through
their own stages
but um
there was just like a piece once i came
out public and and realized wait a
minute i am a muslim i accept this
you know because sometimes when you do
things in hiding it's just between you
um but when you come out public
um
you're admitting publicly that yes i am
a muslim and i'm not scared to say it
um
so
that was one of the most amazing days
uh
in my life that i had
uh just a couple more questions uh
before we're out of time so just for the
for the audience it's just like saying
look i am one who has chosen to submit
my will to god almighty the creator of
allah that says there's something wrong
with that you have a problem with that i
mean most people who are god conscious
you know who believe in the creator of
the heavens and earth they would say no
that's a great thing right but that's
what just that one word muslim that's
what it means it and encapsulates me
saying this whole long sentence of what
i just said so
it's made simple it's made easy so what
was it when you contrast now from going
from methodist church baptist church
non-denominational
or being an ordained minister all of the
things in the confusion like many people
struggle with the trinity
they struggle with god being a man
you know and they love this pure
monotheism to to heed as we call it
islam that you only worship one and only
god the creator the one who created
christian but not his creation that he
created no that makes sense and being
morally upright and then if anybody
reads the quran sincerely humbly looking
for the truth the signs are there
there's so many miracles in the quran
what was it that stood out that you
remember that did it for you
when you contrast what you're upon
before and finally what did it for you
that you finally said no no this is the
truth
what did it for me
um
and
part of me felt when i you know even
though i had transferred over to being a
muslim
um
i still was still searching
and um
i shut down my business
um which i do not ever recommend to any
of the sisters if you ever have a
business and i put a leap of faith i
said you know what if this is is if this
is real i'm taking a leap of faith
i'm dropping everything i and
i wanted to show
that i wasn't i guess materialistic
because i had a lot of material things
and
i i i
i left and i went to egypt
and
things happened over in egypt and then
i met the sisters over there and started
really
the the kindness of the people
that was given to me
just really
opened up the doors
and understanding the quran even more
that
you can't just you know you just can't
take one ayat
you have to understand above and below
and that
there are time periods within
the quran
that are to be used yes into this
lifestyle but we also have to remember
when the quran was wrote
so it's a way of life
you know it's a guide
and
that was right there and like i told my
mom a long long time ago you show me the
true bible and something that was
actually written by god
and i will follow you
and my mother could never do that
and then there's so many different
bibles out there
that you don't know which one really is
the right one
you either so many virgins and every
religion always has all the re you know
they call it the bible but then you've
got the king's virgin the mormons have
their bible jehovah witnesses have
theirs uh protestants have theirs the
methodists have theirs
um verses are missing but there is this
quran
that has never been changed
and masha'allah to have so many people
to memorize that
and that's when
the sisters had told me that it would be
best to be married
and
when i met my husband he was beside her
but he knew so much about the quran and
his
uh
when i was learning more and more of how
to say the words correctly um
the fact that it has not changed
that's just an amazing miracle in itself
you took away the quran totally 100
percent right
now and you could be totally rewritten
in the exact same words
because everybody has memory is so easy
to memorize
it takes a little bit yes and
people will tell you that learning
arabic is hard
and i told them you know what it might
be hard
but if allah wants you to do it it's in
your heart it's going to be easy
and so
to see something to give
to have a quran
that's never been changed
that's what turned
that that that's what showed me that you
know what this is real
this is and i studied our prophet peace
be upon him his life and the way he
treated people and the way he did things
and how he lived
that
the humble
was just that i think was all the
turning points
wow that just uh this last part when you
were going over just gave me chills you
know shot a wave of uh
like electricity through my body just
these chills like hearing you know this
this miracle that many many of us take
for granted it's amazing like the way
you explained it coming from you an
ordained christian minister and now
you're on the program and you're talking
about this it's just alhamdulillah
thank you very much thank you very much
what um
last closing comments and advice for
many muslims you know just uh look
you're
now coming from
the
way of life that you're upon before you
really searched and searched and we're
guided to this deen this way of life
this beautiful way of life and
you know what you're wearing dressing
like mary the mother of jesus wearing
the hijab but you've got a lot of
muslims struggling you know to make
prayer taking the deen for granted when
you see that like what do you want to
say to such people who are born maybe
you know some family but they're taking
their deen you know their this way of
life for granted what advice do you give
them
um
the most advice but and it took me a
while to learn this um i would hear it
all the time
um
um from our destin uh
area
he always and i thought at first when he
said the word that he just didn't know
the answer
um but his one word
was the biggest and the wisest answer
that anybody could give
patience
it's not going to happen overnight
you're going to have tests you're going
to have trials
when you come closer to a law shaitaan
does not like it
and
it's it's like a battle
because he's losing
a body a soul
and
now you're getting closer to allah
but if you
realize
with just a little bit of patience and
when things happen if you could just
breathe slowly breathe in and let it
back out and realize that this is a test
allah is going to be with you all the
time
it states in there that allah will not
give up on you
the only way allah gives up on you is
when you give up on allah
and so the number one thing is patience
take it slow
study what you can
question everything if you can
and if somebody turns around and
mentions a hadith
or mentions something in the quran say
hey
what's the ayat
what hadith number go look it up
because when you look it up and you read
it and it's there that's when
the justification comes in and realizing
wait a minute that
maybe i should
do a little bit more that direction or
wait a minute go closer to allah this
direction
you know put a law first
and remember you're you're going to be
tested
beautiful thank you so much uh for
spending some time with us here on the
dean's show sharing your story
thank you
and thank you guys for being with us
here
on the dean show this is uh
such a wonderful story i hope you got to
uh enjoy it like i did you know just
seeing people who have come from all
different walks of life ways of life
religions
and there's doubts there
things don't make sense they don't add
up
and then they start to question they
don't get the answers but islam has all
the answers
so if you're going to someone and
they're not giving you the answers go to
the next person be humble be sincere be
genuinely looking for the truth and god
almighty the creator allah will guide
you and that's the first place i always
leave my audience with is within
yourself ask ask the creator because it
could be daunting you would think
confusing there's so many different
religions which one is the right one
but you gotta ask yourself
everything has an expiration date and i
will also
and i'll die
we have a departure date so i better get
it right everything has a purpose what
about me what's my purpose in life
and then start to do
this little small thing every day ask
the creator within yourselves guide me
guide me guide me what is my purpose
what do you want from me the one who
created me guide me to the truth and
then look into islam sincerely read the
quran connect with some muslims forget
about everything you've been told all
the nonsense all these
doubts that have been fired your way to
create to confuse you
look and search for yourself
read the quran
go to a mosque connect with a muslim and
ask those questions and see
the answers that come to you and if
you're genuinely sincere a whole new
world of goodness will open up god
willing we'll see you next time
subscribe if you haven't already
here on the dean show peace be with you
assalamu alaikum